jean marc gallant bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de cabinet du préfet du
département des yvelines vous êtes
invités de cette première partie du 7 8
puisqu'on va parler de cette deuxième
édition de la quinzaine régionale en
ile-de-france dédié à la sécurité
routière des usagers vulnérables elle se
termine le 8 juin une centaine d'actions
en tout en ile de france organisée à
destination des piétons des cyclistes et
des deux roues motorisés pourquoi cette
attention toute particulière autour de
cette catégorie d'usagers qu'on dit plus
vulnérables
justement pourquoi dit-on guitton plus
vulnérables parce que ce sont ceux qui
sont les plus sujets aux accidents on le
constate un peu partout dans les grandes
villes enfin dans les zones très
urbanisées notamment dans les yvelines
où les piétons sont très touchées où les
deux roues sont également très touchés
par les accidents de la circulation
on pourrait y ajouter aussi parmi les
piétons des enfants quelquefois des
personnes âgées ce sont
les pommes sera assez de précautions
sera alors tout ce sont les autres
usagers bien attention parce que les
usagers sont vulnérables parce que ils
sont moins moins fort moins puissants
face à l'automobile est souvent et
pourquoi insiste tant sur les usagers
vulnérables parce que finalement nous
sommes tous à un moment donné aux
conducteurs ou usagers vulnérables et il
faut se souvenir chaque avoir le sens
des responsabilités sans responsabilités
sa responsabilité personnelle c'est
aussi de se souvenir qu'on peut être à
un moment donné plus faible dans une
dans une dans un rapport automobile
circulation toujours en sécurité si sa
sécurité dans la voie de la lure sur la
route bien sûr en 2012 un chiffre 1 326
personnes ont trouvé la mort sur les
routes en ile de france 65% justement
étaient des usagers vulnérables est ce
que ces chiffres sont en progression en
évolution plutôt négative sur ces
différentes années
alors le phénomène des usagers
vulnérables et en dix ans elle est
stable malheureusement stable à d'assez
haut niveau
l'amélioration ne peut pas constaté
d'amélioration
on l'a alors ce qu'il faut retenir quand
même des chiffres de la sécurité
routière dans les yvelines par exemple
qu'on constate depuis plusieurs années
maintenant une tendance très nette à la
baisse du nombre d'accidents la baisse
du nombre de blessés là où on a encore
des améliorations à apporter encore des
efforts collectifs affaire concerne les
tuer ou les tuer le nombre de tués a
baissé entre 2010 et 2011 a légèrement
augmenté sur 2012 le début d'année 2013
n'est pas bon on est à 21 tués le mois
de mai était meilleure
le mois d'avril avait été très mauvais
lemoine a été meilleur parce que
justement il ya une plus peut-être plus
de contrôler une prise de conscience
aussi grâce aux retours presse d'un
certain nombre d'opérations et grâce
aussi aux actions qu'on mène dans la
quinzaine régionale vous savez c'est un
an censé les actions de désinformation
mais cela y avoir de la répression aussi
alors il ya des structures des deux ex
bialé de la prévention routière et la
sécurité routière ces deux volets ses
aveux lettres prévention de
sensibilisation
parmi les plus jeunes et c'est un volet
de répression et la répression elle a
déjà lieu la répression ce n'est pas pur
plaisir de constater les infractions de
mettre des pv c'est clairement pour
lutter contre la délinquance routière
d'accord les avs qu'alors en étant payé
par exemple cette année début 2013 plus
de 230 grands excès de vitesse constatés
dans le département ce qui est
considérable ce qui veut dire qu'elle un
grand excès de ses plus de 50 km/heure
par rapport à la vitesse autorisée donc
on n'est pas sur un kilomètre heure ou
deux kilomètres à on est sur un délit on
est sur quelque chose sur un sur un acte
ii sur un acte de délinquance le d'eux
mêmes
constat d'un nombre important de
conduite sans permis de conduire c'est
un tiers dès lors le chiffre global
c'est plus de 3000 infraction routière
constatée depuis le début de l'année
parmi de ces infractions mille
infractions qui sont en fait des
conduites sans permis de conduire ce qui
est ce qui n'est pas admissible
plus de 700 en fraction qui concerne
l'alcool et plus de 100 d'une centaine
qui concerne la consommation de
stupéfiants au volant ça veut dire quoi
que la prévention la sensibilisation ne
marche pas à tous les coups la
sensibilisation la preuve que la preuve
que la sensibilisation marche quand même
puisqu'on constate moins d'accidents
moins de blessés dans le temps sur le
temps long moins d'accidents moins de
blessés ce qui veut dire que la
prévention marche malgré l'augmentation
du nombre de déplacements en automobile
notamment ou en deux roues mais qu'en
revanche un certain nombre de personnes
resteraient frac terre et c'est d'être
ces personnes qu'il faut qu'il faut qui
sait ces personnes là qu'il faut
réprimer justement parmi les actions
menées je vous propose de revenir sur
scène qui se déroulait à coignières
qu'on vient d'apercevoir en images
c'était ce matin sur la nationale 10
elle était cibler spécifiquement sur ses
deux roues motorisés reportage anthony
rech patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est important c'est de juger
vous êtes avec vos amis
l'attestation d'assurance ce qui déjà
une bonne chose on fait une vérification
fichiers
cet habitant de rambouillet plutôt
chanceux arrêté sur la route nationale
10 au niveau de coignières ce motard
aurait pu être verbalisés j'ai changé de
mouscron profond hier et donc j'avais
mon permis de conduire j'avais
l'attestation de vinyan mais j'avais pas
la carte grise on est mieux dans la dans
l'information
que l'accompagnement que dans leur
précision à la place du traditionnel
contrôle les services départementaux de
la sécurité routière sensibilise les
deux roues au bon comportement d'autant
plus que la veille sur la commune un
accident grave a eu lieu entre un motard
et une voiture qui roule à une certaine
vitesse il est vrai mais entre les files
de véhicules ils sont assez prudents
surtout en sachant que quand vous rouler
entre les files de véhicules vous avez
toujours le conducteur de voiture qui
vous faire un dépassement qui n'est pas
sans clignotant et c'est là qu'on arrive
sur un accrochage le méta h 30 heure
c'est certain mais on essaye de leur
faire comprendre justement de faire très
très attention
pendant cette matinée les forces de
l'ordre ont effectué près de 80
contrôles cinq motards ont été arrêtés
pour vitesse excessive
quinze personnes sont convoqués ce
vendredi au tribunal de grande instance
de versailles pour voir leurs affaires
classées grâce à cette opération de
sensibilisation en 2013 cinq motards ont
trouvé la mort sur les routes yvelinoise
cinq motards qui ont trouvé la mort sur
les routes du département l'entendait
dans ce reportage pas uniquement parce
que les automobilistes ne font pas
attention à eux aussi parce que les
motards ne prennent pas de précautions
on l'a vu avec ce reportage quel bilan
on peut faire des opérations de
sensibilisation vous avez menées depuis
le début de la quinzaine est ce qu'il ya
eu un retour plutôt positif lors on voit
ces de la sensibilisation il n'y a pas
de verbalisation systématique donc les
motards le prennent plutôt bien est-ce
que ça a été le cas partout est ce qu'il
ya un moteur positif il le préfet a pu
le constater cet après-midi aux mureaux
par exemple présents sur 20 ans
d'existence le color il est très
difficile d'évaluer le retour de telles
opérations
ce qu'on constate c'est l'intérêt du
public l'intérêt du public des jeunes
beaucoup de jeunes qui étaient présents
pour tout simplement par exemple aller
sur un simulateur de conduite ou un
simulateur deux roues bon on peut penser
c'est l'intérêt de ces actions que
le fait même d'avoir d'avoir essayé
d'avoir vu d'avoir été conseillé quelque
chose en restera le préfet a également
croisé les motards des motards notamment
représentants dans les fédérations qu'on
connaît bien sûr le sujet qui
travaillent avec nous dans le
département des yvelines motards dit en
colère travail avec la préfecture ce qui
permet d'organiser des rallyes fin ddd
rallye moto encadrés par les gendarmes
et là on en constate de tous les
gendarmes constatent eux mêmes des
résultats très positifs à la sortie de
ce genre de sensibilisation pourquoi
parce que les gendarmes partagent leur
propre expérience de conduite explique
comment fonctionne la machine explique
comment on doit la conduire ces choses
très concrètes comme ça on le sait ça a
une influence un effet marqué beaucoup
de partenariats vous avez cité la
fédération des motards en colère il ya
aussi des partenariats avec l'éducation
nationale et des actions sont menées
tous les acteurs sont mobilisés combien
d'acteurs participe au tour aujourd'hui
de l'action vous avez affectueux vous
avez les acteurs publics avons parlé
vous parliez l'éducation nationale a
effectivement par exemple aux mureaux à
nouveau sensibilisation plus 300 élèves
de 4e sensibilisés par dans quatre
collèges différents la police nationale
on voyait envoyait le référent
départemental sécurité routière de la
police à sienne les gendarmes qui ont un
rôle très important parce que ont une
densité de voirie très très forte d'une
autre nature que celle de la police qui
est plus urbaine mais c'est eux qui gère
les autoroutes les grandes nationales et
c'est que les crs donc les trois forces
les trois forces de l'ordre qui
interviennent sur la route également ce
qu'on appelle les bénévoles très
important le préfet d'ailleurs la
souhaitait les remercier tout
particulièrement cet après midi aux
côtés du maire des mureaux ce qu'on
appelle les alors ce sont les
associations bien connu
l'automobile club les la prévention
routière mais aussi des particuliers des
gens y compris des victimes de la route
qui eux mêmes ont choisi un moment donné
de partager leurs expériences pour
sensibiliser aux drames de la vie peut
constituer un accident de la route c'est
ce qu'il faut toujours
ccc la base la sensibilisation c'est que
une imprudence une petite infraction ça
peut être le début d'une collection
d'infraction d'un ensemble de petites
infractions qui vont un jour conduire à
l'irréparable et l'irréparable ce sont
des drames de la vie et c'est ce contre
ces drames qu'il faut qu'il faut lutter
cette quinzaine de sensibilisation
autour de la sécurité routière nous
l'évoquons sur ce plateau la sécurité
routière en marge de cette quinzaine il
en a aussi été question dans l'actualité
plus nationale et même européenne ce
mardi avec elle cette annonce puisque
d'ici au 7 novembre la plupart des
ressortissants européens ne pourront
plus se prévaloir dans un pays de
l'union de leurs plaques
d'immatriculation étrangère cela devrait
même être rapidement le cas en france
dès cet été que pensez vous de cette
coopération au sein de l'europe afin de
lutter contre justement ce toutes ces
infractions routières c'est notre
question du jour
au niveau de la sécurité je trouve ça
intéressant après bon il ya sûrement
d'autres points
à prendre en compte au sujet des excès
de vitesse
que
je veux dire tout le monde soit logé à
la même enseigne qu'il n'y ait pas de
passe droit que
on fait une faute on la paye c'est vrai
que oui effectivement quand les
étrangers viennent en france il paye pas
la moindre quand il retourne quand ils
retournent dans leur pays on ne renvoie
pas la moins on leur envoie mais s'ils
veulent pas payer il a payé par la
sécurité moins de morts sur les routes
que tous les gens quand ils se déplacent
dans les pays étrangers les mêmes règles
il faudrait effectivement harmonisée je
pense que le côté français avec 130 est
pas si mal que ça ou qu'ils aient les
mêmes ring partout sinon c'est quoi
l'europe quand on va au sein de l'europe
bien on peut respecter les mêmes règles
pour tout le monde est allé et partout
donc il n'y a pas de problème tout façon
il ya trop de d'excès faut que ce soit
le code choix sur les européens
finalement l'accord européen ça va
fonctionner c'est déjà une bonne une
bonne solution les yvelines vous avez
souvent des cas de personnes de
ressortissants européens qui sont
flashés et considérait jusqu'à présent
pas sanctionné vous aurez peut-être
l'occasion de faire vous même les
gendarmes par exemple pinceau à la 10 je
les ai déjà pratiqué avec eux sanctionne
régulièrement des conducteurs étrangers
enfin de nationalité aux ressortissants
d'états européens ou d'autres d'autres
états le système sera considérablement
améliorée par là les nouvelles règles
européennes la libre circulation est une
règle fondamentale de l'union européenne
était normal d'arriver à un système de
contrepartie aussi la libre circulation
à sa contrepartie qui est une sanction
possible lorsqu'on commet une infraction
dans les pays traversés mais d'ores et
déjà la gent la police la gendarmerie
les crs pratiquer pratiquer une niveau
de sanction c'est ce qu'on appelle la
consignation jusque là on pouvait pas
aller aussi loin pratiquer la
consignation tu veux dire que la voiture
ne repartait le véhicule ne repartais
que sur paiement qu'après paiement d'une
consignation relativement importante ça
fonctionnera dans l'ensemble des pays où
ça pour les jeunes rats on sait aussi
qu'ils vont se rendre à londres c'est la
contrepartie compris pour un français
qui circulent à l'étranger au code de la
route n'est pas réservé à son pré carré
national on applique les règles dans du
pays dans lequel on circule c'est normal
juste pour conclure puisqu'on parlait de
ces radars est ce qu'il va y avoir des
implantations de radars d'ici à l'été ou
même pendant l'été dans le département
lors il ya déjà un certain nombre de
radars dans département des yvelines qui
pour beaucoup
très très grande utilité bon petit
paradis nouvelle ça veut dire que c'est
pas l'ensemble ça veut dire que les
radars doivent eux aussi faire l'objet
d'une évaluation sont des dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place au cours du
temps fait partie de la politique aussi
sécurité routière s'est dévaluée ceux
qui sont les plus utiles ce qu'ils sont
éventuellement - qui veut pas dire
qu'ils ne le sont pas mais certains
radars sont mieux adaptés à ce pourquoi
les installer d'autres leçons qui
pourraient être redéployés ailleurs
seulement ça fait partie des hypothèses
il ya un train des travaux sont menés
régulièrement et d'évaluation sur ce
sujet alors des nouvelles installations
nombreuses non on n'est plus dans une
phase d'installation lourdes ont déjà
beaucoup mais par contre sophistication
des dispositifs ça peut consister
notamment installé maintenant des radars
des radars tronçons il ya quelques
projets dans le département
lui installations également récemment de
radars discriminants qui permettent de
distinguer l'automobile du poids lourds
par exemple certains secteurs du
département voilà c'est tout cet
ensemble de mesures qui est qui est mis
en oeuvre évaluation l' évaluation
évaluation et déploiement de systèmes
plus élaborés qui permettent encore de
répondre au mieux aux besoins mais le
radar est nécessaire le lampadaire et
paraissent du jour hollande appelle la
vitesse est avec l'alcool l'alcool et la
vitesse sont les deux causes principales
d'accidents mortels
partout en france mais notamment dans
les yvelines donc on ne relâche pas
l'effort sur ces deux sujets merci à
vous la quinzaine régionale de la
sécurité routière a donc qui se poursuit
jusqu'au 8 juin avec des actions de
sensibilisation des contrôles aussi sur
le bord des routes et puis bien sûr
rester vigilant au volant ou derrière le
guidon tout au long de l'année c'est pas
uniquement sur une période de
sensibilisation que c'est important
merci à vous